une vibrante vaccination n'a pas utile
mais ce n'est pas ce que je vous dis je
encore une fois je vous dis pas que la
vaccination n'est pas utile je vous dis
simplement qu'ils doivent être ciblés
cette pop et cette maladie elle touche
une partie population qui ne risque rien
donc il n'ya pas imposer des mesures
obligatoires pour cette population et
c'est l'oreille à l'enfant de la scène
dans la dernière heure durant à la
demande si
ça peut arriver l'argument du pathos
quand on n'a rien à dire monsieur en
l'occurrence est-ce que l'emballement
ses remords c'est toujours grave mais
est ce que pour un maire doit appliquer
un pass vaccinale des restrictions
liberté du mas un masque partout non je
vais vous dire une chose il y avait des
déprogrammations lors des précédentes
crises mais il y avait des hôpitaux qui
saturaient il y avait des grèves
souvenez vous il avait des grèves des
urgentistes est-ce qu'on a fermé le pays
pour autant est-ce qu'on a imposé des
masques pour autant nous on ne l'a pas
fait notre société a changé
qui dit oui je veux des winamax mais
attention je dis oui à cette question
faut-il être plus sévère avec les non
vaccinés le chômage moi je dis qu'il
faut un empêcher les neuf accusés de
vivre normalement pour les pousser la
vaccination quoi vous voulez mais en
revanche il faut pas les empêcher de
vivre tout court on l'espère chômage
c'est quand même merci donc pas les
empêcher de vous les tuez moi j'en ai
fait moi je suis je suis pour être plus
cher parce que j'en ai assez ça fait
deux ans qu'on prend des demi mesures
moi j'étais en tremblant fermé trois
doses j'ai peur du vaccin parce que
j'entends tellement de choses j'en ai
peur mais je le fais notamment pour ma
mère je les fais j'ai tout bien fait
j'ai fait vous n'imaginez pas le
parcours du combattant parce que ça on
n'en parle jamais le parcours du
combattant pour faire vacciner excuse
moi parce que c'est très dur une dame de
90 ans qui a les nerfs vous imaginer
comment on peut la vacciner je me suis
battu pendant des mois ce n'est pas
trouver une personne qui se déplace à
son domicile pour la faire vacciner sa
saison là ils font partie les
non-vaccinés aussi je n'ai fait vacciner
qu'en août alors que c'est la chose à
laquelle je tiens le plus parce que je
ne trouvais personne et qu'on ne peut
pas l'emmener elle va hurler elle va se
débattre c'était c'était horrible
c'était un moment ça c'est parcours du
combattant là il ya des gens
certainement alors peut-être parce que
simplement ils sont isolés dans des
zones rurales il ya des gens qui
voudraient se faire refaire la guinée
qui ne peuvent pas moi je pense que les
anti pacs et des problèmes de riches
suis désolé si ça aujourd'hui combien y
aurait une mort en plus sa vieille ville
s'est sauvé des milliers de millions de
monde dehors pardon dans le monde entier
sur et donc elle il faudrait aussi
parler de ceux qui aimeraient se faire
vacciner ma mère j'ai trouvé enfin une
infirmière qui venait elle ne vient que
le 1er février je tremble parce que là
on est maintenant elle a quel âge je
tremble pendant dix ans il ya 92 ans on
a des raisons sur vaccinés oui à 30 40
50 ans quand on aurait dit je me suis
alors voté l'obligation vaccinale le
débat et si madame je respecte votre
souffrance et le débat ici c'est pas
l'efficacité du vaccin on n'est pas
scientifique je suis pas son nom mais
c'est pas là visible est ce qu'on va
imposer à toute une population
l'obligation de se vacciner sous peine
de sanctions alors qu'il ya des gens qui
sur la balance bénéfices risques n'ont
pas ces racines et c'est ça le sujet
madame s'est pas fait mes
classes et loris de 48 beaucoup mais
dont on vous l'avait bien
dit pour sa création qui est vaccinée
vous le voyez bien je suis le gars dès
la première haute et damas qui
naissaient il ya quand même beaucoup
moins de changer de direction il est
très évident avec un baril à
la tôle ah oui
alors déjà moi je suis pas du tout pour
ce qu'a dit estrosi je trouve que c'est
ridicule c'est rajouter de la précarité
à la précarité ça n'a aucun sens et en
plus c'est illégal mais ensuite pour moi
la vaccination ce n'était pas une
question de avoir le commis de pas avoir
le convive le problème on est d'accord
c'était d'ambo lisez et services de
réanimation et les hôpitaux on est
d'accord donc c'était pour éviter les
formes graves donc en fait qu'il y ait
quatre cent mille cas on s'en fout oui
je suis d'accord avec vous
justo
400 mille cas c'est 400 milles 6 et 4
400 mix est pas cachée dans les îles h
je suis d'accord avec vous alors que la
vaccination voit il me semble que c'est
très bien moi je suis pour le pass
vaccinale j'estime que dans trois mois
ya des élections il des amendements
sénat qui sont qui vont donc très d'être
dans cet accident et que maintes fois
vous mais à trois fois si vous êtes en
train de vous transformant dalmatiens
[Rires]
on
va très bientôt vacant une troisième
coup il s'abat en revanche non moi je
pense qu'en fait vous voyez les
élections les élections vont tous
balayés si les gens ne sont pas d'accord
avec ce qui a été fait par par le
président macro et par son gouvernement
et puis voilà et puis le sénat a choisi
des amendements qui sont très concret et
très précis annonce l'assemblée
nationale balawi était retoqué non pas
du tout ils vont être balayés gérald et
bien sûr ils vont vous l'assemblée c'est
la république et l'assemblée a toujours
le dernier mot dans la salle par nos
rêves